[Musique]
je parle des albums 2020 quand
restera-t-il 2021 la course folle et
aujourd'hui 2023 les immortels donc
toujours chez Sony vous êtes resté
fidèle à même maison de disques voilà
alors j'ai entendu dire que enfin je
vous ai entendu dire pardon que ce
disque selon vous le quatrième les
immortels étaient le plus abouti de vos
albums vous l'avez dit ça oui je l'ai
dit peut-être que je me suis un peu
menti parce que je voulais savoir ce que
ça voulait dire non en fait je pense que
par plus abouti je pensais le plus libre
le plus le plus jusqu'au boutiste dans
mes idées dans mes convictions
artistiques dans un certain lâcher prise
dans une voilà en s'apsoudre des
attentes de de toute forme de pression
retrouver une forme d'ingénuité de du
premier instant du moment où on s'est
rencontré sur cette scène place du
marché à Versailles
retrouver
ouais cette forme de brûlure un peu
innocente de faire de la musique voilà
il y avait cette idée de liberté et de
plaisir et ça c'est difficile à acquérir
vis-à-vis de la maison de disque où je
l'appelle moi je suis très libre je suis
très
autonome dans ma création mais il se
trouve que on est dans une époque qui
quand même
à des formats parfois un peu
ingrat dans lesquels il faut s'inscrire
pour être à tout prix visible et en même
temps voilà les gens sont curieux il y a
aussi de la place pour tout ça il a dit
il y a de la place pour un disque qui
s’écoute peut-être plusieurs fois il y
en a plein pour des albums qui ont
besoin de lenteur d'endurance qui sur
lesquels il y a des plages
instrumentales des ritournelles des
motifs pas forcément des refrains comme
des hymnes mais en même temps
voilà je suis très content de qui est
dans le sens plus abouti c'est peut-être
là où je me montais un peu je crois que
aucun disque n'est le plus abouti qu'un
autre c'est juste une photographie d'un
instant il faut pas trop lui en demander
d'accord et voilà c'est déjà énorme déjà
qu'il existe c'est déjà
si magnifique alors donc vous l'avez
réalisé celui-là de A à Z contrairement
aux autres ça a permis justement cette
fameuse liberté j'imagine ouais bien sûr
alors déjà il y avait un rapport au
temps qui était différent dans la
création parce que j'avais mon studio
dans lequel j'ai arrangé le disque vous
y alliez quand vous vouliez autant aussi
longtemps que vous vouliez complètement
parce qu'il est même Souché moi donc je
descends c'est votre studio
et j'arrive dans mon espace mon
laboratoire de travail et donc de
n'avoir aucune prise sur le temps
c'était extrêmement précieux parce que
je je pouvais aller au bout de de
exactement et donc ça a pas été un
disque qui est né dans le premier jet
c'était très bien après j'étais pas
complètement seul il y a des copains qui
sont venus enregistrer dessus et ça
c'était assez différent aussi pour la
première fois j'avais disons une banque
de son enregistrée de guitare de base de
corde est-ce que vous faites tout seul
alors Patou non non les guitares les
basses c'est pas moi les cordes c'est
Lucas Henry qui les a arrangés il y
avait Thomas Clairis à la base François
Lasserre aux guitare par exemple et pour
la première fois les arrangements sont
aussi dessinés
une fois que tout était enregistré je
suis allé découper dans de la matière
vivante
organique pour agrémenter quand même une
ossature piano-voix de toutes ces
touches plus électroniques et parfois
assez cinématographique mais en tout cas
à les ciseler un peu tout ça je
comprends et justement en parlant de
voir moi j'ai l'impression que sur cet
album votre voile est un peu différente
pas sur certains morceaux et
je connais pas grand chose mais j'avais
envie dire une voix de tête ou j'ai
l'impression que vous utilisez
différemment votre voix oui sur cet
album il y a une prise de conscience de
mon instrument qui est
volutive moi j'ai pris des cours de
chants assez tardivement en fait et là
la dernière tournée m'a quand même fait
prendre conscience de mes capacités
vocales plus que jamais et je pense que
je me suis vachement plus amusé avec la
voix sur cet album il y a en effet
beaucoup de voix de tête position du
larynx en haut sur une voie assez
aérienne plus chantée avec des textes
aussi qui sont moins fleuves et du coup
ce qui donne la place à des mélodies
peut-être peu davantage que quand on est
dans un truc assez parlé chanter par
exemple on parlait de TER Centre il y a
moins de place pour une mélodie vraiment
poussée parce que le texte est très
dense là il y avait aussi l'idée d'aller
à l'os et à l'essence aussi sur les
paroles ce qui laisse plus de place pour
la voix mais quand je comprends mais
justement parlant de cette écriture j'ai
l'impression qu'elle a une place très
très importante pour vous dans vos dans
vos chansons elle est très ciselée comme
vous dites les mots sont vraiment
choisis c'est pas les rimes qu'on entend
amour toujours enfin bon bref il y a une
vraie originalité dans le sens que ça
vient de vous de votre régime en tant
qu'être et du coup je me dis quelles
sont les conditions nécessaires pour que
vous puissiez écrire qu'est-ce qui vous
inspire est-ce que toujours de cette
fameuse mélancolie est-ce que c'est un
peu la sève dans laquelle vous trempez
votre votre plume voilà je crois que
tout est conditions encore une fois on
parlait de TER mais c'est pas
anecdotique ça a été un révélateur pour
moi de création cette chanson
de pouvoir parler d'à peu près tout et
aussi d'à peu près rien et à savoir
qu'un trajet en banlieue à ses quotidien
voilà on est quand même dans quelque
chose de l'ordre de la monotonie de la
petite es de d'un ordinaire qui qui
n'est pas très séduisant et en fait de
ça aussi on peut tirer quelque chose
donc je crois que ça vient d'à peu près
tout j'ai l'impression que c'est surtout
une curiosité c'est avoir envie de
croquer des trucs il y a un truc de
gourmandise aussi moi j'aime écrire
parce que parce que je vis des choses et
je pense que c'est plus important de
vivre des choses que de lire des choses
pour avoir envie d'écrire et d'être
transcrire et évidemment après
c'est c'est submergé infusé par tout ce
qu'il y a autour et avoir envie d'en
restituer des sentiments des bribes des
impressions je vous propose une chose
qu'on écoute en extrait de ce nouvel
album c'est la chanson amor voilà qui
est magnifique
[Musique]
je suis dans la ville
un peu de ta présence
on dit de ton profil
que vienne la délivrance
[Musique]
au cinéma
les flammes l'eau et le givre
mais tu n'y étais pas
un mot
je voyais le ciel
j'ai croisé les anges
voilà c'était à mort
qu'est-ce que vous
allez vomir qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous avez envie de nous dire sur cette
chanson
c'est marrant parce que c'est peut-être
la chanson qui est la plus je dirais
dans dans un exercice de style à la fois
musicalement je me suis amusé à je les
coproduites avec Paco del Rosso qui qui
produit notamment les albums de damso
donc il y avait quelque chose d'assez
contemporain assez fusion à la fois de
musique latine très sensuelle chaloupé
et voilà de pour le coup de parler
d'amour sans trop surprise non plus mais
avec une certaine latinité un truc un
peu chaud
c'était déjà dans l'album d'avant dites
moi et si je m'écoutais vraiment la
chanson numéro 1 qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'elle révèle cette chanson ça veut
dire quoi vous empêcher de faire des
choses elle révèle une un état des lieux
de de se poser face justement à une
feuille blanche et je m'étais fait cette
réflexion tient peut-être que je ferai
les choses différemment si vraiment je
m'écoutais intimement en dehors des
attentes des carcans etc et en même
temps c'est une liste à la fois de
choses tout à fait atteignables parce
que plutôt positif c'est pas trop non
plus chimérique mais est-ce que c'est
souhaité et c'est souhaité mais en fait
ce qui est marrant c'est je crois que
les mêmes choses aujourd'hui forcément
d'accord ça change en tout cas oui ça
change vite évidemment mais parce que
l'époque change vite aussi mais je crois
qu'il y avait quand même il y a des
choses qui se retrouvent encore c'est un
besoin de lenteur un besoin de silence
de retrouver quelque chose d'un peu plus
essentiel
ouais quelque chose qui sort un peu de
la brièveté et de l'urgence de l'époque
dans laquelle on est et sinon je me
disais qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
postures actuelles qui semblent
comment dire un peu obligatoire pour
pour l'image quoi pour que l'importance
de l'image dit j'ai pas mettez-vous en
bermuda avec des grandes chaussettes
faites des couettes faire des trucs
comme ça vous restez vous restez
vous-même tel que vous êtes sans
artifice est-ce que c'est compliqué dans
le mine dans le métier dans le milieu de
d'être soi-même point non il y a une non
il y a une place il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de d'artistes très très
sincères enfin d'ailleurs la plage la
plupart des artistes sont très sincères
après évidemment peut-être que
c'est parfois une industrie qui qui
demande du spectaculaire
de la séduction quelque chose de d'assez
grandiloquent moi je suis pas trop là
dedans j'aime bien la sobriété j'aime
bien le minimalisme les pures et donc
oui j'essaye de rester fidèle à ça ouais
et vous m'aviez dit je conçois mon album
d'une façon un peu réac
ça voulait dire quoi c'était je pense
de comprendre ce qu'est un album à
l'heure où on écoute de la musique de
façon playlist et son iPhone sur des sur
des trucs assez individuels aléatoire
qui passe très très vite à autre chose
sur les plateformes de streaming sur
Youtube etc moi je suis encore très
attaché au format et à l'objet d'un
disque d'accord je trouve que c'est très
important dans ce que ça raconte comme
histoire
d'avoir un objet avec un track listing
avec plusieurs chansons une tracklist
quoi une cette liste un ordre de chanson
pour le côté français
qui raconte quelque chose et qui
s’écoute comme ça et moi je suis attaché
à ça vous faites bien parce que cet
objet est magnifique et alors en pré mon
art certes le texte des chansons mais en
plus on a on suce j'ai envie de dire des
textes in oui des dessins et donc voilà
ça conforte ce que vous dites quoi c'est
c'est vraiment un objet et c'est unique
alors moi j'ai l'impression que cette
c'était comme ça la dernière fois aussi
vous aviez écrit des textes en plus des
chansons
qui sont associés à chaque chanson à
travers un lieu l'idée c'était de
raconter un lieu un endroit qui qui
correspond aux chansons et donc des
endroits ouais assez important pour moi
dans la création et et d'associer ça
aussi avec des dessins d'Albane tricot
pour prolonger l'imagerie de des
immortels et ça vous tenterait
l'écriture purement littéraire un livre
quoi de plus en plus je suis à fond
dedans c'est vrai c'est un exercice qui
est bouleversant qui est passionnant
c'est tout à fait autre chose justement
je parlais de ce cette lenteur
l'espace littéraire est absolument
inouïe parce qu'il offre une liberté
totale
un esprit de nuance aussi qui est
extrêmement précieux une chanson c'est
synthétique c'est un format assez court
là on a quand même plusieurs centaines
de pages pour exprimer toute une idée
assez complexe et ça ça me plaît
vachement c'est un roman et puis il y a
pas d'image on parlait d'image
et c'est un roman un roman autobio
intimidant mais mais c'est à fond et je
suis à fond dessus et vous le finirez
quand vous finirez ou vous savez déjà un
peu je pense que ça ça l'année prochaine
il devrait vous parvenir
ça c'est une super nouvelle bon en
attendant vous n'allez pas arrêter la
musique
mais par contre on peut aussi voilà un
état des lieux où j'ai quand même la
sensation d'avoir fait 4 disques
rapprochés peu de temps quatre bébés
très rapprochés c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure et ça a été dix années de
ma vie merveilleuse
pleine de pleine de découvertes de
rencontres j'ai énormément de gratitude
et de reconnaissance pour tout ce que
j'ai traversé mais je crois que j'ai
besoin aussi de
vivre autrement que par ça et
je crois que ça ne peut qu'être
bénéfique aussi de savoir s'absenter à
un moment
j'ai soif de ça quand même d'accord ok
et justement alors votre public parce
que je pensais à votre public si vous
arrêtiez la musique se donnait
évidemment pas question mais quel
rapport vous avez moi j'ai une idée mais
je me demande j'ai un rapport je crois
assez sain assez festif simple
j'aime bien le voilà ce que je construis
pour l'instant avec ce que je conçois
être mon public qui est très très
il y a des grands-parents il y a des
gens installés il y a des gens dans dans
une nouvelle naissance non il y a ça me
plaît beaucoup et de sentir qu'on parle
pas qu'un type de personne très
différent c'est des gens qui sont
touchés artistiquement je crois parce
que je fais en même temps qu'ils le sont
simplement c'est un rapport assez sain
et en même temps voilà j'aime
principalement retrouver ce public là
sur scène parce que c'est c'est là pour
moi l'endroit véritable du lien et de la
transmission et c'est vrai que tout ce
qui est réseau j'ai un peu plus de mal
quoi et donc on peut dire qu'il y a
vraiment une proximité
j'ai envie de dire d'amour enfin d'amour
pour votre musique mais amour ou
infection pour vous quoi c'est je pense
qu'il paraîtra il y a une affection
justement peut-être dans dans cet esprit
d'être
un personnage d'être dans une vraie
simplicité pour moi
l'idée de célébrité elle est fétiche
elle est elle est tout simplement
construite et j'aime bien la
déconstruire parce que voilà c'est un
truc d'humain à humain et après il y a
aussi toute une dimension à respecter du
cadre privé et cetera mais je crois
quand on montre beaucoup de simplicité
généralement c'est ce qu'on ne renvoie
en retour et ça me va très bien voilà il
y a des artistes très populaires que
j'admire parce qu'ils sont restés aussi
dans dans quelque chose de
ouais de
simples et de voilà le la simplicité et
pas et pas un gros mot
et en Belgique en Suisse c'est pareil
ouais
super public en Suisse et en Belgique
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance de faire pas
mal de concerts à la barre
invité pour parler de mes disques et
c'est des pays que j'aime bien qui on
sent que l'écoute est différente
peut-être qu'en Belgique il y a il y a
peut-être un peu moins de snobisme parce
que c'est un pays qui est à la croisée
de plusieurs cultures il y a il y a
évidemment cette dualité entre Wallonie
et Flandre qui qui prête à écouter des
langues différentes et des formats aussi
qui sont peut-être parfois plus
audacieux mais j'aime bien ça du coup ça
permet de d'aller voir ailleurs
exactement super alors du coup prochaine
date de concert je crois que c'est le 2
novembre au Trianon c'est ça à Paris
c'est pas demain dites donc non c'est
pas demain c'est à l'automne et je suis
très content pour une fois d'avoir un
espace entre la sortie d'un disque et le
début d'une soirée oui généralement
c'est plutôt ça l'ordre des choses et là
ouais je suis super content parce que ça
allait la possibilité à ce disque de
vivre déjà chez les gens d'être
découvert de jouer d'endurance encore
une fois parce que voilà il a besoin de
ça je crois et puis d'arriver sur scène
avec les crocs et finalement cette cette
dalle là cette fin de scène elle sera
j'en suis sûr d'autant plus puissante
que que ça s'inscrit pas dans un truc
trop trop fermé sans d'une sortie
d'album je comprends et vous serez en
pleine forme et je serai en méga à
pleine forme
bronzer sur la la pochette qu'est-ce que
c'est que toutes ces paires de fesses je
suis pas le plus bronzée mais j'ai pas
été voir de près
je la trouve magnifique cette pochette
de Diane Sagnier prise dans les
calanques du Frioul l'idée c'était de
trouver quelque chose d'assez primaire
presque animal
de sensuel mais de mais avec une vraie
pudeur aussi une mise en scène que je
trouvais élégante on a envie de se
déverser dans ces eaux de palines des
calanques et puis de de goûter à la
saveur d'un soleil méditerranéen et puis
il y avait cette un peu aussi de mettre
un petit coup de canif sur sur quoi sur
cette juvénilité et cet aspect assez
lisse que qui fait partie de moi mais
mais j'aime bien parce qu'elle est je
vois quelle questionne et le et c'est
étonnant mais je vois que cet album vit
aussi à travers sa pochette c'est vrai
et ce qui est assez rare mais eux elle
marque et là je vois qu'il y a des gens
qui découvrent le disque par la pochette
bon bah écoutez je vous souhaite plein
de succès merci
cool
il y a un bel accueil et puis voilà on
fait pas uniquement ça pour ça mais
quand même je dois reconnaître que là la
reconnaissance est précieuse un grand
merci Tim DOP d'être venu jusqu'ici et
puis à très vite peut-être pour un roman
j'aimerais bien et puis je vous souhaite
de bonnes vacances et puis une belle
tournée après merci merci à bientôt ciao
au revoir à tous merci de nous avoir
suivi
[Musique]